scientists at the quantitative
Biosciences Institute at the University
of California San Francisco have been
working nonstop since January
their goal identifying existing
medications that make human cells
resistant to attack by the corona virus
what we're trying to do is to repurpose
those drugs and compounds to help fight
this corner viral infection it's called
host directed therapy the host in this
case is us first scientists had to
extensively map the virus's genetic code
and the parts of human cells that it
latches on to we identified 332
different human proteins that were
talking to the approximately 30
different viral proteins so these are
proteins that we think the buyers needs
in order to hijack ourselves so from
this analysis we identified 69 different
drugs and compounds 27 of which are FDA
approved and we need to test those to
see what effects they have on infection
unfortunately labs in San Francisco
didn't have any virus cultures to run
tests on that's when the global
cooperation kicked in we broke down
silos across different parts of the
world and working with Paris and New
York and then also people in England and
Seattle and San Diego and in China and
we've been shipping them our drugs and
compounds and they've been testing these
dr. croghan is hopeful an effective drug
will be identified within weeks and
since the drugs are already approved
they wouldn't have to undergo a lengthy
testing process instead they could be
available for patients right away the
example of urgent cross-border
multidisciplinary scientific
collaboration is a model for fighting
future outbreaks dr. Croghan says when
the dust settles on Kulpa 19 i would
love to see us put in an infrastructure
where we can move quickly across the
board you know breaking down these silos
so that would be in a better position
to tackle Cova 22 or kovat 24 are
another buyers there are millions of
trillions of viruses on earth and far
fewer scientists given those odds all
experts must work together for the sake
of humanity
Rob Reynolds al-jazeera Los Angeles